still developing at 11 police on the
scene of a deadly shooting happen in the
far northwest valley all this unfolding
at an apartment complex not too far from
farm and hualapai let's get right out to
sasha loftis she's live in that
community with why police are calling
this an avoidable tragedy sasha
denise and bryan the deadly shooting at
an apartment at this complex here all
stemmed according to police from someone
playing with a handgun that unexpectedly
fired we're told this all started around
seven o'clock this evening several men
in their 20's were socializing at an
apartment at this complex here and one
started playing with that gun the
handgun then reportedly went off
shooting and killing another man police
tell us it's important for anyone
handling a gun to consider safety first
to prevent something like this from
happening
one of the rules of firearm safety is
any gun that you are holding is
potentially
a loaded weapon so
especially when you're playing with a
handgun in a setting like this this is a
tragic outcome to a situation that is
completely avoidable
as for the person police say fired the
gun police tell us it's too early to
tell if he will face any charges but
officers do stress that this is an
ongoing investigation and it will
continue to develop so stay with 8 news
now for that information as we continue
to get it in the coming days reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now